shigella is well known for its role in
enteric disease and it caused shigolosis
a intestinal disease which is very
common among children
is gram-negative non-motile non-spore
forming and it belongs to the
enterobacteriacy family
shigella can be transmitted via
contaminated water or food or even it
can be transmitted via fecal to oral
root
shigella bacteria invade the lining of
large intestine and leads to severe
inflammation and it leads to damage of
the large intestinal cell which
ultimately lead them to die during the
acute illness the organism can be
cultured from stools and it can be
isolated in hectons agar or salmonella
shigella agar as it's a bacterial
disease it can be treated with
ciprofloxacin or azithromycin and oral
rehydration might be useful what's the
full